but I refuse to accept that it is
somehow Britain's Destiny to fall back
into middle League status or that the
tax burden reaching a 17 a 70-year high
is somehow inevitable it isn't and it
shouldn't be
we needed a new we needed we needed
conference we needed a new approach
focused on raising economic growth
because that is the only real way to
deliver opportunities to deliver higher
wages to deliver more jobs and crucially
to deliver that Revenue to fund our
precious public services and it is the
best and only way of achieving long-term
fiscal sustainability
because it is only by raising economic
growth that we will spread opportunity
and prosperity to every corner of our
country with economic growth everybody
benefits and I mean everybody
while we all believe in growth we as
conservatives also believe that it is an
important principle that people should
keep more of the money they earn I don't
need to tell you that
I don't need to tell you that
I know I don't need to tell you that
that isn't radical that isn't
irresponsible it is a deeply held belief
that we all share as conservatives we
were faced with a 70-year high tax
burden we were confronted with low
growth and the path we were on was
clearly unsustainable
so that's why we are cutting taxes for
working people that's why we will
reverse the National Insurance hike on
the 6th of November and that's why we
will bring forward the 1p cut to the
basic rate of income tax by one year
that's why that's why that's why we will
take 200 000 people out of paying stamp
Duty altogether taken together this is
what our support will do for all our
people
thanks to our energy intervention a
typical person in a semi-detached
property will save 1 150 pounds on their
energy bills this winter on top of the
400 pounds discount and if they are
earning an average salary they will
benefit from an additional tax cut of
around 400 pounds that is almost a 2 000
pound saving this year alone
but I can be frank I know the plan put
forward only 10 years days ago has
caused a little turbulence I get it I
get it
uh we are listening and have listened
and now I want to focus on delivering
the major parts of our growth package
because with energy bills skyrocketing a
painful coveted aftermath war on our
continent as 70-year High tax burden
slowing Global growth rates and
glacially slow infrastructure delivery
we couldn't simply do nothing
we can't sit idly by what Britain needs
more than ever is economic growth and
the government wholly committed to
economic growth that is why we will
Forge a new economic deal for Britain
but by an ironclad commitment to fiscal
discipline more businesses
more businesses more jobs higher paid
more money for public services because
we cannot have a strong NHS without a
strong economy we can't have good
schools without a strong economy we
cannot fund our Armed Forces without a
strong economy so growing our economy
should be our Central and guiding
mission
with this plan we are aiming for two and
a half percent annual Trend growth we've
done it before and we can do it again
and even in the face
and even in the face of extreme
volatility in global markets with major
currencies wrestling and incredibly
strong US dollar and longer term Trends
from demographic change to climate
change we will show that our plan is
sound
that it is credible and that it will
increase growth that is our pledge to
the people of this country